I am awesome I am great I am going
places
I'll stop you ever done affirmations in
the middle of it you kind of listen to
yourself saying I can't do this anymore
this is very very weird and awkward
we're gonna talk about a complete
different strategy for affirmations
you've never heard of before that will
absolutely work for you so before I get
into the episode if this is your first
time visiting this channel this is the
number one channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs if you've never subscribed
to the channel please do so we've got a
lot of different videos over a thousand
videos on how to raise money how to hire
how to fire how to scale a lot of cool
interviews mafia interviews Mark Cuban
interviews Kevin Hart Kobe Bryant many
different interviews you can watch here
as well again if you haven't so please
do so let me get right into the episode
daily affirmation so I want to share
with you openly what I have here a
couple of things you got to keep on mind
how I came about with affirmations is an
evolution so for me when I first got out
of the military and I went into sales my
sales manager told me Pat you got to
have some affirmations it's very good
then I started reading books and
everybody said affirmation affirmation
affirmation right and the whole idea
about affirmations is what because - to
compensate for all the years that your
parents rejected you or you growing up
you will reject it and there's a book
called and the genius in all of us and
in the book the author talks about how
lower-income families kids have been
rejected six hundred thousand times from
zero to 18 then it says middle-income
families from zero to 18 have been
rejected a hundred thousand times
meaning a hundred thousand more
negatives than positives an upper-class
family children have a hundred thousand
more affirming you know positive
statements than negative statements
that's in a book in the genius of all of
us we'll put the link below if you want
to buy the book it's a good book now so
you have some of you if you if you were
raised on a long term family like I'm a
welfare kid parents got a divorce you
don't hear a lot of positive oh you can
get them all you can get this and you
can do that that's not the environment
so I started collecting all these
affirmations I mean I can tell you I
literally have an entire folder here and
here
when affirmations I mean I would go to a
piano store the one I'm looking at right
now is the four surefire rules for
success show up pay attention ask
questions don't quit you know I'd go and
get affirmations from restaurants the
winner the winner is always a part of
the answer you know attitude the longer
I live the more I realize the impact of
attitude on life persistence my daily
affirmations here's one of them very
basic ones I have a positive attitude
attitude about everything I will always
be respectful be the best speaker ever
I'm a great speaker I will touch many
people's lives before I leave this
planet I will read this three times a
day I'm the greatest miracle on the
planet I'm you know I will I have never
and will never be a normal person I will
persist until I succeed I have a great
body and physique I make everyone happy
around me this is my affirmation at 21
years old that I have till today 19
years ago Abbott and by the way again I
can go through a bunch of them here okay
so but as I'm going and doing this one
day I told myself there's got to be a
different way of doing this if you ever
came into my apartment from 22 years old
on I always had three four of these
things on the shower wall everywhere I
had it on my wallet I had it on my
speedometer my car I had it in my office
I had it on my computer I had it
literally taped up everywhere these
affirmations and I would read them but I
wanted to take it to a whole different
level and here's what happened so you
know on a flight back once from Chicago
I started writing things down and I
start kind of taking an inventory of
this guy's life okay so it was very
simple it was Pat what were the five
most painful times in your life okay
most painful and I start writing them
down the time you almost lost your dad
okay the time your girlfriend and you
and her we're gonna get out of the army
and you call back and she got into a car
accident and she passed away it's 20
years old okay Monica you know the time
you know you have to say goodbye to your
dad in 1989 Airport Elon Iran while
we're going to Germany and my dad gives
me a hug my sister my mama right behind
me we've gone to Lufthansa flights the
last time I saw my that for a year and a
half two years very difficult for me but
I remember that so I wrote these things
I'm not gonna tell you all of them
there's a lot of them it's more than
but I wrote these things down and it was
painful and I have to think about a
little bit and it was painful and I
ranked them so that was five right there
then it's writing out five most
successful moments of your life
when did you win you know what's
interesting today I was talking to one
of my consultants and I'm talking to the
guy and I said I want you to tell me
three times in your life were you one
and you were absolutely amazed with what
you did here's what he said he says let
me get back to you on this one
the man is forty-five years old he said
let me get back to you on this one he
couldn't think about in that moment why
is that very simple why that is because
our mind is filled with layers and
layers and layers and layers of memory
that's filled with so much juice that we
never tap into think about it this way
your computer you have in your house can
you tell me every file you have in your
computer can you tell me every Excel
spreadsheet you got every Microsoft Word
you know if files you got every
PowerPoint can you tell me every file
every image every video every music
every recording you've ever done every
can you tell me all of that could you
tell me that no but if you unpack your
computer you ever done that when you go
certain documents you're like oh my gosh
I can't believe I wrote this nine years
ago oh my gosh I can't believe I wrote
this eight years ago and it starts
reminiscing and produces a certain
emotion right the mind is just like that
except a hundred times more powerful
because it's not logic it's emotion but
because we don't tap into it we don't
know how to bring that juice out so stay
with me here five most painful five most
successful moments five most painful
statements so moments are different than
statements moments as someone died
statements are you will never do
anything big with your life ever do
anything big with your life okay never
our MVP the company we announced last a
few weeks ago in Las Vegas you know he
was told that in 2008 by his former
mentor he told him you will never do
anything with your life he remembers it
till today
and it's a way that produces juice for
them if they ever needs to tap into it
it's one method of juice to tap into
right so you got five phrases what are
the most five painful phrases that you
write down okay so so far we got what
painful moments okay we have successful
moments we have painful comments and
last but not least is moments where you
felt untouchable so what do I mean by
this let me explain something happens in
the family its crisis they're trying to
solve a problem they come to you you
come into the room everybody send their
panic in you say have we thought about
doing this no have we thought about
doing that no how about this no and
you're very confident let me make a
couple calls boom boom boom boom boom
here's what I think we do have you guys
thought about if we go first here first
your first you know here's what we need
to do we need to call this person call
that person call this person
everything's gonna be fine okay
hey Barton said yes yes you make the
call Papa Papa Papa all of a sudden hour
later everybody was panicking
everything's solved in that moment you
get a feeling of six people and room
couldn't figure this out five of them
are older than me I came and I led the
family I wonder what I can lead in my
life you have those who you know you
have those moments you're watching this
you're saying I have those moments back
I know you have those moments but you
don't take inventory go in here stay
with me we're still talking about
affirmation so watch this imagine I am
your director we're doing a movie
together you're playing Bobby you're
supposed to talk to Johnny you do your
role you mess it up over take 2 take 3
take 4 take 5 take 6 take 7 I can't
stand it you're not doing a good job you
can't get it I pull you set that's a
come here that's can I talk to you for a
second yes I said do you remember the
first time a girl broke your heart
yes what was her name Mary okay do you
remember when she ended up dating a guy
who she started dating in the first time
you met the guy you made eye contact and
he had a smirk on his face he tried to
control it to not smile but he knew he's
hooking up with your girl that used to
be with and she shattered your heart
because you know your girl told him
about you
on how he shattered you on how she
shattered your heart do you remember
that look on his face I do remember the
look on his face see that guy right
there Johnny
that's your girlfriend's boyfriend
that's him
I want you to get in that state and then
go to your lines yes I'll give you a
couple minutes go prepare
get mentally there come back please
don't talk to anybody when you do come
back you're gonna play Bobby you're no
longer you you're Bobby yes yes please
go and I want you to go deeper and
deeper and deeper and deeper and deeper
with additional things that was said and
happened that can produce more juice go
get him and you step away then he come
back you talked to Johnny Johnny's
shivering because he really believes
that you believe you're Bobby what
Johnny doesn't know is you purposefully
went to state in your life that you
remember the boyfriend that your
girlfriend was dating and then oh you're
in that state that's what great actors
do what great actors do is they have an
arsenal of stories and moments in their
lives that they tap into this is why
some of the best actors in the world
were former military former distich
parents got a divorce mom was an
alcoholic or dad was an alcoholic the
more stories that they have the more
they can get into that moment the
singles are business as well by the way
so think about it right now you're about
to go give a speech you're about to go
into an appointment you're kind of
nervous because it's a big appointment
so if you just go to deployment you're
not gonna be as effective as you sitting
there saying this is a big appointment
Johnny let me tell you something it was
December 2nd 2003 when I walked into the
meeting with the family nobody had any
idea how to handle the situation I did
if I handled a complicated situation
like that on our family that had to do
with a loss of a loved one I can close
this deal today let's get into that
state Johnny to get into their state let
me get into the state then you walk into
the appointment and you're a whole
different human being that little
conversation with yourself changes your
state now by the way some people say
well Pat you mean to tell me people
really do this stuff yes so now let's go
back to affirmations basic level
affirmations is what your ass
you're great you're amazing your this
your dad your this it's still effective
it's still good I'm not taking anything
away from it I just I have a hard time
with hokey affirmation stuff you know
what I'm saying like yeah as long as you
said you're gonna do great stuff I know
I know so many people that do have
formations that doesn't nothin for them
right here's why let me give you the
second part of affirmations here's how
it works
so the first part of the affirmation is
the statement I am a great leader okay
the first part of affirmation is I will
make a great comeback I will make a
comeback story that's great I will make
a great comeback that's great but it's
not at the highest level it's at the
highest level when you follow up and you
say I will make the greatest comeback
story because I'll never forget what
happened when my mother died because
I'll never forget what happened when
such and such a relationship didn't work
out because I'll never forget when I
filed bankruptcy and I lost everything
because I'll never forget when I lost my
house and my car was repo'd and I was 22
years old living on my friend's couch
and I made the sickest comeback and I
got my own house
I got $200,000 in the bank I got this I
got this I got that I'm gonna make the
greatest comeback ever because I've done
it before I can do it again that's an
affirmation wood weight behind it that's
what you need to be doing so every time
you have your list of affirmations that
you add add it with a story so know grab
let me go back to it again five things
right
five what five painful moments five
successful moments five painful
statements and five moments where you
felt you were untouchable the way you
handled yourself where you were
untouchable moments where you're like I
came through it was a pressure type
situation I was calm I handled so I'm
sharing this with you with the
affirmations I want to put a PDF below
for you to go out there and download to
actually put the answers for yourself so
you can click on the link below to be in
the description section to get it but I
want to take a level deeper with this as
well so you know what you have to
understand what I'm going through this I
was doing a podcast yesterday and a guy
asked me a question and he says he says
hey Pat I got a question for you I said
what is it he said what gave you
confidence to see that you can go and do
what you're doing right now with your
life I said it's interesting you say
that and I've never talked about this
before so let me let me see what I can
come up with no preparation nothing I
said you know it's funny I don't know
why but one of them was and this applies
to a lot of people you've experienced
this before as well yourself even if
it's a glimpse I don't know why but I
think number one is fate he says faith I
said no no fate what do you mean by fate
I think there's an element of me you
know I've had glimpses everywhere I felt
like I was destined to do something
special in my life
it's almost like a higher loss counting
on me to come through and do something
big
so fate was one of them he says
interesting what else I said faith is
the second one he says oh really what do
you mean by faith I said faith is I
don't know why I feel like God a higher
spirit
it's got my back I don't know how to
explain it to you it's as if think about
you put Bruce Lee the most scariest MMA
fighter u.s. UFC fighter everybody
toughest guys in the world they all have
your back and then multiply times 100
imagine if you got that kind of backing
what kind of confidence would you have I
feel like I have that so faith is one
faith is to number three is the
following and a lot of people don't do
this I got so clear on my vision then I
told everybody about it then the right
people showed up out of nowhere just
accidentally they started showing up
because people now know what you're
looking for so faith faith casting your
vision here's what we're gonna be doing
and this is why this is our vision
here's what we're looking for people
show up and I said last but not least is
luck
and he says luck really not a lot of
people like to talk about luck I said
yeah I believe it look at luck is a part
of it so he said you mean you mean luck
like really getting lucky isn't and when
people say you know I work hard I don't
get the harder you work the luckier all
this other stuff I said no I said I
think I'm the luckiest person in the
world I really believe that by the way I
really believe unlocked is human being
alive i when i tell you i really i
didn't believe this before i believe it
today you know why because of these
formulas because of these formulas i did
it so much with the formula I gave you
that eventually this guy believes it
this guy believes it this guy believes
it's like pure confidence on division
on the clarity of it and it produces
this energy and I know this may sound
weird to some people but I challenge you
to do it here's my challenge for you go
download the PDF below write down five
most painful moments five most
successful moments 5 4 most painful
statements 5 most untouchable moments
and then tie it with a list of your
affirmations I'm great I'm a could come
back I'm gonna do this I'm gonna make
that kind of money I'm gonna do this
part
tie you to that and do it for a month
and see what happens to you by the way
I'll give you the last thing that I used
to do so I took all that stuff and I
added my affirmations then I recorded a
six-minute six-minute audio and I had my
guy add music to it I liked trans
lower-level trans not high beat a little
lower level trance and I put that
together was the trance song of a
Braveheart you know done no no no no no
no the Braveheart trance like this and I
put my affirmations for six minutes and
thirty seconds and I recorded it and I
said Pat you gonna place his body here's
why do you member that one town what
happened here's what you did do you
remember that I know you remember that
day so you got this and I recorded this
and back then it was CDs cuz nowadays
this you can put on your phone listen
just a lot easier back in there with CDs
so I put it in my car I put it in my
office I woke up to it I worked out to
it I was driving listen to it I was
sleeping to it everything - no no no no
no no no no no no no no all over again
and then eventually it's stuck and this
guy started believing it and you can do
the same thing as well but it takes a
little bit of discipline and actually
putting time into it for this to become
a reality so go download the PDF I got
two other videos I want you to watch one
of the videos I did years ago Marty I
don't even know when this video was I
want to say four years ago was 2015 I
think is this video it's one of the back
in the days when we had you know 15,000
subscribers 10,000 subscribers I did
this video titled how to break the curse
of your limiting beliefs okay how to
break the curse it's a very emotional
video I'm not holding back in this video
it's I think that she shot the video on
December 31st or something like that
when the video ends live if you've never
watched it's it's old-school its raw not
the best audio not the best editing but
it's a great video if you haven't seen
it go watch this and the other video I
suggest you watch is also three types of
Chambord this affirmation has a little
bit to do with vision boards I suggest
you watch both of the videos and again
at the end go download the document as
well for you for you to be able to fill
out the information and you can kind of
get your affirmation lists together if
you haven't subscribe to the channel
please do so
take care everybody love you bye bye